you've come to an impasse yes
love one another yes
I didn't pass a guess well
let's try working through that empath
shall we
I don't think Harper understands me I
don't know if
I'll ever be enough for him
it's a feeling I can't shake it he's
always reaching always reaching for
something more something else Harper do
you feel as if there's any truth to what
Robin is telling you of course you are
enough for me I I lean on her for
guidance I wouldn't be where I am today
if it was not for her my success is her
success what about my success
of course you lean on me too I'm rooting
for her for us what is that face you see
how she sucks her teeth like that do you
feel as though your priorities are alive
no oh okay they are not Robin Harper
thank you
I feel like I mean we love each other we
both want what's best for our daughter
and uh
you know I think we're good people so
I guess so Harper is um
a great Daddy
and when he's loving towards me I feel
it but that all takes a back seat to his
work
and I don't want to be put in the back
seat
I don't want to be not not anymore not
anymore Harper
what are you feeling
uh honestly I feel attacked I feel
blindsided confused I don't know where
this is coming from see I've never see
see what I mean he gets so defensive he
doesn't want to listen to my wants my
needs who I am as an individual not as
his wife or Mia's mother but Robin Robin
before now do you feel as though you've
made your needs known to Harper
foreign
I mean I don't want to Badger him
um or or
be a knack
I guess I I guess I do just
kind of keep my thoughts to myself
I just follow his lead
we can't expect our partners to be mind
readers and then be mad when they are
not I'm not a mind reader
neither am I
but I think of you
I consider you
I guess what I've been doesn't always
get the best version of me
um
I tend to focus on what's next instead
of
what is but I'm trying to be better
and I'm trying
to wait for that to happen
[Music]